[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers
guten Abend in allen Paragraf 293 der
russischen
Strafprozessordnung erlaubt allen
Angeklagten ein Schlusswort unzensiert
auch denen die vor Gericht stehen weil
sie etwas gesagt oder getan haben was
dem Machthaber im Kreml nicht gefällt es
ist das letzte Wort
ich bitte dieses Gericht um nichts ich
kenne mein Urteil das ist in Russland
der Preis dafür dass man nicht schweigt
lieber als ehrlicher Mensch zehn Jahre
hinter Gittern verbringen als schweigend
und in Schande in dem von der eigenen
Regierung vergossenen Blut zu schmoren
glauben Sie mir hinter Gittern gibt es
viel mehr anständige Menschen als in der
Regierungspartei Einiges Russland
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Zeit
haben eine ganze Reihe von diesen
letzten Worten zusammengetragen Alex
Heiner wallny hatte am Ende eines neuen
weiteren Prozesses gegen ihn gesagt
jeder in Russland weiß wer Gerechtigkeit
vor Gericht sucht ist komplett
ausgeliefert heute kam sein Urteil
Vertraute des russischen Oppositionellen
hatten schon vorher gesagt dass genaue
Strafmaß spielt eigentlich keine Rolle
denn es ist klar Präsident Wladimir
Putin villner weil nie nicht mehr in
Freiheit sehen heute wurden es noch mal
19 Jahre Haft wegen Extremismus
Vorwürfen und es geht nicht nur um Navi
für
dass sibirische Barnaul liegt grob
gesagt in der Mitte von Russland
3.700 Kilometer von der Hauptstadt
entfernt auch hier hatte alexener valny
einen Stab aufgebaut auch hier wurde der
verboten Maxim aus muskin fährt mit
unserem Team zudem Gefängnis in dem der
ehemalige Leiter des naval niestabes
jetzt sitzt
natürlich weiß man hier über ihn
Bescheid also diejenigen die
interessiert sind die kennen ihn aber
das Problem ist dass die meisten sich
für gar nichts interessieren
Korruption oder den Krieg zu kritisieren
Alexa unterstützen das reicht den
Russland um wegen des Vorwurfs des
Extremismus verurteilt zu werden für
neun Jahre muss war dem astanien in Haft
Maxim bringt ihm Lebensmittel ins
Gefängnis steht mit war dem in
Briefkontakt wie es im wirklich geht
weiß er trotzdem nicht
verstehen sie die Briefe werden dort ja
immer zensiert wir schreiben er schreibt
was als unmöglich zu schreiben gilt wird
aus dem Text gestrichen
vielleicht schreibt er was vielleicht
schreibt er nicht
Berichte darüber dass politische
Gefangene in Russland gefoltert werden
gibt es viele auch aus der Strafkolonie
ik6 hier sitzt alexener wallny eine
9-jährige Haftstrafe aus einem anderen
Verfahren ab und hier wurde der
oppositionelle heute schuldig gesprochen
eine extremistische Organisation
gegründet zu haben 19 Jahre strenge
Lagerhaft für Putins schärfsten Kritiker
es gebe in Russland keine unabhängigen
Gerichte mehr erklärt hat Jana babavic
sie hat als Anwältin im naval nicht
starb von Barbara gearbeitet
hat wie die Daumenschrauben angezogen
wurden wie die Diktatur an Stärke
gewonnen hat
na walnies Auftritt heute nach zwei
Jahren im Gefängnis nach vielen Wochen
in Einzelhaft so sieht einer aus der
sich von Putins Regime nicht brechen
lassen will
per telegram Nachricht wendet er sich
nach dem Urteil an die Russinnen und
Russen sie wollen nicht mich sondern
euch einschüchtern und vom Widerstand
abhalten ihr werdet gezwungen euer
Russland einer Bande von Verrätern
Dieben und Schurken zu überlassen
die Sicherheitsbehörden beobachten ganz
genau wer hier ein und ausgeht trotzdem
treffen sie sich in Badener Uhl
regelmäßig um Briefe an politische
Gefangene zu schreiben damit die
Kremlkritiker und Kriegsgegner hinter
Gittern wissen sie sind nicht allein
Kyrill martinof ist Chefredakteur der
Tageszeitung novaja gasetta Europe die
nur noch online erscheinen kann und
nicht mehr in Russland Herr Martin auf
guten Abend
guten Abend sie mussten auch selbst ihr
Land verlassen was macht denn so ein
Urteil wie das heute gegen einen mit
Ihnen ganz persönlich
dieses Urteil ist nicht nur ein Urteil
gegen verbal nie sondern gegen die ganze
russische Gesellschaft die bürgerliche
Gesellschaft die versucht unabhängig von
der Regierung zu sein und die versucht
eigene Meinungen und Werte zu haben
was glaube ich nah dran ist an
europäischen Werten und im Moment sehen
wir dass diese Aktivitäten in Russland
völlig kriminalisiert werden
und die Regierung erklärt einen zum
Terroristen oder Extremisten nur weil
man Präsident Putin kritisiert und
man glaubte man hätte politische Rechte
in Russland und das war das eigentlich
Verbrechen von der Waldi
und was macht das mit ihnen haben Sie
möglicherweise Angst auch vor dem langen
Arm des russischen Staates
keine Angst und ich hoffe
dass die Menschen die gegen Putin und
seine Regierung und seinen schrecklichen
Krieg sind auch nicht ängstlich sind
aber ich verstehe dass viele Menschen
den Russland leben müssen dass die
möglicherweise verängstigt sind wegen
dieser Sache weil sie ihren Mund nicht
aufmachen können gegen Putin gegen seine
Regierung oder dessen kriminellen Krieg
und das ist ja letztlich das Ziel dieser
Verurteilung viel zu Zeiten Stalins
heißt das würden Sie sagen diese
Einschüchterung des Staates gegenüber
den Menschen funktioniert tatsächlich
oder anders gesagt wie würden sie das
beziffern wie viele Menschen in Russland
sind tatsächlich gegen den Krieg und wie
viele dafür
ich würde sagen dass die Europäer wissen
können und wissen müssen dass es immer
noch Billionen in Russland gibt und
wahrscheinlich Dutzende von Millionen
von Mensch die gegen den Krieg sind wir
wissen dass denn die Menschen schauen
sich ja unsere Videos an und die lesen
unsere Geschichten
und
Sie können trotz der Zensur diese
unabhängige Stimme aus dem Ausland
wahrnehmen und
es gibt verschiedene unabhängige
russische Medien die Millionen von
Lesern haben Zuhörern Zuschauern und das
ist eine historische Aufgabe für uns
sicherzustellen dass diese Menschen
immer noch verbunden sein können mit dem
globalen Fluss der Information von
richtigen Journalisten und das ist
unsere einzige Möglichkeit die wir der
Demokratie und eine normalen Leben in
unserem Land in einer fernen Zukunft
helfen können
lassen Sie uns bitte noch über die
Opposition in Russland sprechen na weil
nie war ja vergiftet worden in Russland
danach Deutschland gebracht worden ins
Krankenhaus und er ging dann freiwillig
wieder zurück nach Russland in dem
Wissen dass er dort verhaftet würde was
sagen sie hat sich das gelohnt dafür
dass er jetzt in Lagerhaft sitzt
wollte bei seinem Volk sein bei seinen
Fehlern er wollte Teil der russischen
Gesellschaft sein das war seine Wahl
ich weiß nicht ob das politisch wirksam
war
ob es pragmatisch sinnvoll war aber
dahinter steht immer noch ein großer
moralischer Wert und eine moralische
Bedeutung für das russische Volk und wir
wissen seine Wahl zu schätzen und wir
wissen auch und verstehen dass im
schlimmsten Falle
niemals wieder nach Hause zurückkehren
wird wenn Putin während der nächsten
Jahre an der Macht bleiben wird
diese moralische Bedeutung können Sie
uns das noch ein bisschen mehr erläutern
bitte was kann er erreichen aus der Haft
durch sein Vorbild
er hat keine Angst
das Wichtigste an diesem moralischen
Wert ist keine Angst vor Präsident Putin
zu haben
ich kann es nicht direkt vergleichen
aber es ist wahrscheinlich die gleiche
Wahl die die Ukraine ergriffen haben
während dieser kriminellen Aggression
durch die Russische Föderation und
Präsident Putin sie haben gesagt sie
haben keine Angst vor der russischen
Aggression und in der Waldi hat gesagt
der hat keine Angst vor der russischen
Diktatur das war die moralische
Bedeutung seiner Wahl die er getroffen
hat
na weil nie hat mal gesagt zu glauben
dass es besser würde wenn Putin ersetzt
würde durch ein anderes Mitglied der
herrschenden russischen Elite das sei
naiv also ein Russland ohne Putin würde
eben nicht automatisch zum liberalen
Rechtsstaat wie sehen Sie das
die Geschichte und die Geschichte sagt
uns dass nach dem Tod des Strahlens kein
Wunder geschah die oder erstes er wurde
nicht plötzlich ein besserer Ort oder
veränderte sich nicht völlig sie haben
das kommunistische Regime nicht
verlassen aber gleichzeitig wurden viele
politische Gefangene freigelassen die
Repression wurde milder
und sie wurden ein Land das verschiedene
Schritte zu Normalisierung ergriffen hat
und man muss realistische sagen dass
jede Regierung nach Putin ein paar
Schritte ergreifen muss um ihre
Beziehungen zum Rest der Welt zu Europa
zu normalisieren das könnte also
passieren noch während der Lebenszeit
unserer Generation der entdeckt hat
Poren können nicht zu lange überleben
Deutschland und Russland wissen das ganz
genau
da stellt sich immer auf einen langen
Kampf für die Freiheit ein aber sie
trotzdem möglicherweise ein bisschen
Hoffnung Grill Martin noch war das
Chefredakteur der Tageszeitung nur
Weiher gasetta Europe er macht ihn auf
ganz herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
heute Abend
ich danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir aus
technischen Gründen vor einer Stunde
aufgezeichnet jetzt nach Deutschland es
gibt einen Rechtsanspruch aber es gibt
auch die Realität und da scheint der
Rechtsanspruch wenig zur gelten seit
genau 10 Jahren sagt das Gesetz alle
Kinder über ein Jahr alt in Deutschland
sollten einen Kita-Platz bekommen können
tatsächlich fehlen für die Altersgruppe
unter 300 tausende solcher Plätze und
selbst wer einen Platz hat kann sich
nicht darauf verlassen über die Hälfte
der Eltern berichtet in einer neuen
Studie von Problemen aufgefangen meist
von den Müttern Sandra Susanka mit mir
Frühstück in der ökumenischen Kita
Killesberg in Stuttgart
[Musik]
momentan werden hier 110 Kinder ganztags
betreut bald könnten es noch viel mehr
werden denn wegen der Kita Notlage
greift das Land Baden-Württemberg zur
notwendigen Maßnahmen pro Gruppe können
zwei Kinder zusätzlich aufgenommen
werden bis zu 30 dürften dann von zwei
Fachkräften betreut werden die überall
dringend gesucht werden
warum Bewerbungen wir brauchen Menschen
die sich für diesen Beruf interessieren
wir brauchen Menschen die sich dem Beruf
mit Herz und Leib widmen wollen dafür
müssen wir aber Bedingungen schaffen die
attraktiv sind attraktiv ist momentan
nur wenig an dem Job Kita-Leiterin AIDA
kieflu kann sich noch gut an ihre
Ausbildungszeit zu Erzieherin erinnern
die ersten drei Jahre hat sie ohne
Vergütung gearbeitet musste im
Supermarkt joggen um ihr Leben zu
finanzieren Azubis geht es bis heute so
erst bei Berufseintritt verdient
Fachkräfte in Vollzeit rund 1.800 €
netto insgesamt 4 Milliarden Euro für
dieses und nächstes Jahr sollen nun in
alle 16 Bundesländer fließen damit die
kita-qualität sich verbessert doch das
soll nicht alles sein so die
Bundesfamilienministerin heute trotzdem
sind wir aber gemeinsam mit den Ländern
und Kommunen jetzt dabei eine
Gesamtstrategie für Fachkräfte zu
entwickeln weil die Personalsituation ja
nicht nur in den Kitas
prekär ist nicht Fachkräfte müssen immer
häufiger einspringen die Ansprüche an
die Kitas vor allem durch die Eltern
wachsen Erzieher sind am Limit das
zeigen Studien da zeigte sich eben auch
dass ein gutes Drittel der Fachkräfte
sich überfordert fühlt durch Kinder
diese Tendenz dieses Gefühl die Kinder
sind in Anführungsstrichen schwieriger
geworden das hat in den letzten Jahren
zugenommen und es hat sich gezeigt das
sind Zusammenhang zwischen geringerer
Kompetenz der Fachkräfte und in der
Belastung ihr geringer die Kompetenz ist
desto höher ist die Belastung das
Grundproblem zu kurze Öffnungszeiten
wird jetzt noch mal verschärft durch den
Personalmangel das trifft in den
Familien vor allem die Frauen die diese
Engpässe überbrücken müssen und damit
den Arbeitskräftemangel auch noch in
anderen Bereichen vergrößern
fast die Hälfte der Frauen sind in
teilzeitbeschäftigt viele würden gerne
mehr arbeiten wenn sie denn könnten wenn
vor allem ist bessere Vereinbarkeit von
familienberuf gebe besseres Angebot an
Kita Plätzen bessere Qualität deshalb
liegt jeder Schlüssel die er Frauen
Erwerbstätigkeit zu verbessern allein in
Baden-Württemberg müssen 7000 Fachkräfte
jährlich dazukommen um den Bedarf in
Kindertageseinrichtungen zu decken
ab 2026 wird es übrigens für Kinder im
Grundschulalter in Deutschland einen
Rechtsanspruch geben auf eine
Ganztagsbetreuung in der Schule ein
weiterer Anspruch an dem sich die
Realität dann messen lassen muss und so
steht zu befürchten ein weiterer
Papiertiger
so jetzt einen Blick auf die erste
Nachrichtenübersicht heute die hast du
Hanna ja da schauen wir zunächst
Richtung USA dort musste der frühere
US-Präsident Trump gestern Abend zum
dritten Mal binnen weniger Monate wegen
einer Anklage gegen ihn vor Gericht
erscheinen und plädierte wie erwartet
auf nicht schuldig Trump wird versuchter
Wahlbetrug vorgeworfen außerdem geht es
um seine Rolle bei der Stürmung des
Kapitols im Januar 2021 sind die bisher
schwerwiegendsten Vorwürfe gegen den
Ex-Präsidenten nach der Anhörung
bezeichnete Trump das Gerichtsverfahren
als politisch motiviert
die Ukraine hat nach eigenen Angaben bei
einem Drohnenangriff auf den russischen
Schwarzmeerhafen novozis ein
Marineschiff Russlands schwer beschädigt
der Kreml erklärte dagegen die Attacke
abgewehrt zu haben
Videoaufnahmen sollen den ukrainischen
Einsatz in der vergangenen Nacht und
außerdem die Beschädigungen des
russischen landungsschiffs zeigen
die litauische Regierung plant zwei
seiner sechs Grenzübergänge zum
Nachbarland Belarus zu schließen Grund
sind die dort stationierten russischen
Wagner Söldner ihre Zahl wird auf etwa
4000 geschätzt erst gestern hatten
Litauen und Polen nach einem gemeinsamen
Treffen einen stärkeren Schutz der
Grenze angekündigt weil sie
Provokationen von Machthaber Lukaschenko
und der wagnertruppe befürchten
nachdem Militärputsch in Niger sind
Vermittlungsversuche der
westafrikanischen Staatengemeinschaft
ecovas laut Medienberichten gescheitert
eine Delegation sei ohne Gespräche mit
der Militärführung wieder abgereist
iGO was hatte mit militärischer Gewalt
gedroht sollte die sollten die
Putschisten den abgesetzten Präsidenten
bazoom bis Sonntag nicht wieder
einsetzen unterdessen haben laut dem
Auswärtigen Amt mittlerweile alle
Ausreisewilligen deutschen das
westafrikanische Land verlassen der
Nacht landete ein Flugzeug der
Bundeswehr mit 32 EU-Bürgern im
niedersächsischen Wunstorf darunter 10
deutsche
nach mehreren Koranverbrennungen
verschärft nach Schweden nun auch
Dänemark seine Grenzkontrollen grund sei
eine veränderte Sicherheitslage sei
nötig den Blick stärker darauf zu
richten wer nach Dänemark Einreise
erklärte das Justizministerium mehrere
Koranverbrennungen hatten zu massiven
Protesten in einigen islamischen Ländern
gesorgt mit juli stürmten Demonstranten
die schwedische Botschaft im Irak
[Applaus]
der vierte august wird auf immer
eingebrannt sein in das Gedächtnis einer
ebenso faszinierenden wie geschundenen
Stadt 4 August 2020 der Hafen von Beirut
Libanon
heute drei Jahre nach der verheerenden
Explosion bestimmt die Katastrophe das
Leben in Beirut auch drei Jahre danach
ist nicht klar was genau dazu führte und
vor allem wer verantwortlich ist und ob
überhaupt jemand dafür jemals zur
Rechenschaft gezogen wird
libanesische Verhältnisse oder wie die
Menschen dort sagen unsere Regierung hat
das getan
drei Jahre wurde sie alt Alexandra ihr
einziges Kind damals
ihr Gesicht schmückt heute die
renovierte Wohnung sie spielten zusammen
im Wohnzimmer als die Explosion geschah
jede kleine Glasscherbe wurde zum Messer
bis heute wissen die Eltern nicht wer
verantwortlich ist für Alexandras Tod
wir versprachen ihr Gerechtigkeit aber
wir sind weit davon entfernt wir sind
traurig frustriert und wahnsinnig wütend
leider leben wir in einem Land mit einer
Kultur der Straflosigkeit seit
Jahrzehnten schon die die Ermittlungen
behindern sind Teil des politischen
Systems
bei Ruth heute bis zur Staatsspitze
wussten Politiker Bescheid dass über
Jahre Tausende Tonnen Ammoniumnitrat im
Hafen gelagert waren die Explosion
Sinnbild für den Zerfall des Landes
verursacht von einer korrupten
politischen Kaste die sich auf Kosten
der ärmsten bereichert
die Landeswährung durch die
Finanzbetrügereien der Banken wertlos
geworden acht von zehn Bürgern Leben in
Armut nicht einmal an ihre eigenen
Ersparnisse kommen sie heran
mariams Küche heißt diese Essensausgabe
tausend warme Mahlzeiten am Tag und
psychologische Hilfe finanziert durch
Spenden
das gesamte soziale Gefüge im Land sei
auseinander gebrochen berichten die
Helfer es gibt keine Mittelklasse mehr
eine Krise nach der anderen hat sie
gebrochen
was bleibt ist ein riesiger Schmerz
viele Leiden körperlich und seelisch was
einen völlig fertig macht ist die
komplette Abwesenheit des Staates die
komplette Abwesenheit staatliche
Einrichtungen
William nun verlor seinen Bruder in der
Explosion er war Feuerwehrmann
seitdem kämpft er für einen gerechten
Prozess doch genauso wie die politischen
Eliten den Untersuchungsrichter mit
Strafanzeigen lähmen bedrohen sie mutige
Menschen wie ihn
es gibt so viel Druck auf die
Hinterbliebene das Militär und der
Sicherheitsapparat schränken ihre
Bewegungsfreiheit ein nehmen sie fest
oder beschädigen ihren Ruf die Eltern
eines getöteten bekommen Probleme im Job
oder werden plötzlich auf der Straße
angegriffen
bei Rot heute wieder Trauer wieder Wut
auf die mächtigen im Land die
Hinterbliebenen geben keine Ruhe ihre
Hoffnung dass Europa und die USA Ihnen
helfen Libanons Führung zur
Verantwortung zu ziehen
ab dem dritten Jahr wird aus Wut
Verzweiflung schreibt die in Beirut
lebende Schriftstellerin Lina Munser wir
merken wieder einmal dass das der
Libanon ist in dem die mächtigen nie zur
Verantwortung gezogen werden und keine
Gerechtigkeit waltet
Hannah du machst jetzt in der Sendung
weiter mit Nachrichten aus der
Wirtschaft ja ganz genau unterschauen
wir auf eine überraschende Meldung aus
der deutschen Industrie die konnte im
Monat Juni nämlich einen ordentliches
Auftrags Plus von sieben Prozent
verbuchen positive Nachrichten also
Stefanie Barrett wie passt das zu
ansonsten ja ziemlich trüben Stimmung in
der deutschen Wirtschaft ja man wundert
sich es zeigt aber vor allem wie stark
doch Schwankungen und Sondereffekte das
Gesamtbild verändern können zu verdanken
ist das völlig unerwartet dicke Auftrags
plus der deutschen Industrie vor allem
dem sogenannten sonstigen Fahrzeugbau
dazu zählen Schiffe Züge Fahrzeuge aus
dem militärsektor und der
luft-bauer Airbus die Großbestellung
einer indischen Airline an Land ziehen
500 Airbus Maschinen im Wert von gut 50
Milliarden Euro dieser Deal hat nicht
nur die industriebbilanz ins Plus
gezogen und den heftigen
Auftragseinbruch im ausgeglichen von dem
Auftrag profitieren dürften auch
Zulieferer des Mittelstands die Zahlen
geben aber auch darüber hinaus noch
einiges her zwar gingen im Juni
Industrieaufträge im Inland leicht
zurück Auslandsbestellungen legten aber
um 13,5% zu und allein aus der Eurozone
kamen sogar fast 30 Prozent mehr
Aufträge das heißt die Nachfrage aus
Europa macht durchaus Hoffnung natürlich
Ökonomen mahnen weiterhin zur Vorsicht
und es bleiben auch die Sorgen über zu
hohe Energiepreise und eine insgesamt
schwache Dynamik der Weltwirtschaft aber
es gibt eben auch immer wieder die
überraschenden Lichtblicke wie auch beim
DAX der beendet die Woche nach Verlusten
der letzten Tage heute im Plus
vielen Dank Stefanie für deine
Einschätzungen
Deutschlands größter
wohnimmobilienkonzern muss im zweiten
Quartal einen Milliardenverlust
verbuchen aufgrund fallen der
Wohnungspreise wertet das Unternehmen
seinen Immobilienbestand erneut ab und
zwar um 2,7 Milliarden Euro zudem machen
bonovia die steigenden Zinsen zu
schaffen der Konzern will deshalb
tausende Wohnungen verkaufen um seine
Schulden zu verringern
sind blutartiger Regen hat für
Überflutungen und Hochwasser im Süden
Österreichs und im angrenzenden
Slowenien gesorgt die Lage sei ernst so
dass slowenische
Verteidigungsministerium dort starben
drei Menschen in Folge heftiger
Regenfälle zahlreiche Ortschaften sind
durch Erdrutsche abgeschnitten
Einsatzkräfte versuchten eingeschlossene
Anwohner aus den Fluten zu retten und
auch im Nordwesten Georgiens kamen
mindestens elf Menschen ums Leben 30
werden noch vermisst hier gerieten
Erdmassen nach tagelangen heftigen
Regenfällen ins Rutschen
bei der rad-wm in Glasgow hat Emma Hinze
im 500 Meter Zeitfahren auf der Bahn
Gold geholt damit gewann die 25-Jährige
ihren insgesamt achten WM-Titel
Teamkollegin Lea Sophie Friedrich
sicherte sich hinter der Australierin
Christina Klonen Bronze Pauline Graber
schrundete als fünfte das starke
deutsche Ergebnis ab das Trio Unterboden
erst gestern seinen eigenen Weltrekord
im Teamsprint
matschige Bierdosen und schlammtänze vor
der Bühne Heavy Metal Fans interessiert
aktuell vor allem der Wetterbericht für
das Dorf Wacken in Schleswig-Holstein
und da tun sich tatsächlich ein paar
Wolkenlücken auf nach dem Dauerregen das
Festival stand kurz vor einer Absage
aber dann lief es doch heute zum
Beispiel mit mega Death und Iron Maiden
und deutlich weniger Fans als eigentlich
Karten hatten die Veranstalter müssen
zehntausenden ihren Eintritt
zurückzahlen wer es hin geschafft hat
erlebt mehr als Musik wie Klaus Thomsen
zeigt
laut ist er wild und ungezügelt und
sogar gar nicht jedermanns Sache
warten dieser Ort in der
schleswig-holsteinischen Provinz
verwandelt sich jedes Jahr im Sommer zum
mecker dieser ganz speziellen Musik wie
viele Metal heads ist in diesem Jahr auf
das Gelände schafften ist noch unklar
deutlich weniger als die üblichen 85.000
doch die feiern ihre Musik ihre Kultur
und ihre Gemeinschaft auch in diesem
Jahr wie im Rausch
es geht viel um Zusammenhalt und es geht
viel
ja um das gemeinsame Erleben dieser
Musik dieser Energie die in dieser Musik
steht eine Energie die einen ganzen Ort
seit 33 Jahren verwandelt Watten feiert
mit steht Kopf und dröhnt vor Mettel ein
riesiges Familienfest bei dem wie
selbstverständlich Legenden des Metal
wie Iron Maiden zu Wurst und Bier mit
der dorfmannschaft von Wacken zum
fußballkicken Antreten was macht den
Zauber von Metal aus
Menschen Limette hören ja alle
sympathisch es ist Leben
anderer Lifestyle einfach schöne Musik
ist das ist einfach
Herz
gesehen noch schlimmer aus als ich
und ich mach einfach am meisten Bock ist
laut witzig die Leute sind geil
viele Mädels sind die Jahre gekommen
doch der Nachwuchs schläft nicht in
Wacken stehen jede Menge Newcomer auf
den kleineren Bühnen das Internet
eröffnet ihm möglich
junge Bands können sich halt so eine
Fanbase erspielen das war damals
vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger weil
man war abhängig halt von den Leuten die
was Vereinen dann machen so zum Beispiel
die Plattenfirma und heute kann man viel
selber machen
ziemlich ungewöhnliche neue Form Metal
zu genießen sprießen aus dem Boden so
das inzwischen legendäre Metal Yoga der
professionellen Yoga-Lehrerin Saskia
Tode Metal und das eigentlich doch so
besinnliche Yoga wie passt das nur
zusammen
das müsste man eigentlich beim Yoga
erreichen möchte dieses diese innere
Ruhe finden und Besinnlichkeit finden
und so dieses einfach nur glücklich sein
dass ob das Mittel ist oder ohne Mittel
das erreicht man so oder so aber ich
finde Mittel geht das tatsächlich besser
es bleibt ein bisschen Magie für
Eingeweide bei der Sache
wenn du es nicht fühlst dann verstehst
Du sowieso nicht laut wild und frei
Metal bleibt für viele Menschen fast
etwas wie ein Lebensweg
[Musik]
oder wie es in der offiziellen Lage
Einschätzung der Polizei heißt alles
weiterhin friedlich bei echtem
schiedwetter
wir möchten Ihnen noch unser heute
journal Update empfehlen gegen
Mitternacht mit Christopher Wehrmann und
von uns allen hier auch den Kolleginnen
und Kollegen hinter den Kameras ein
angenehmen Abend tschüss tschüss
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter für alle
die darauf warten ab Mitte nächster
Woche wird es wärmer der Temperatur
Trend für München zeigt uns Mitte der
Woche kommt die 30 Grad so langsam in
Reichweite davor müssen wir aber durch
ein ziemlich ungemütliches und auch sehr
kaltes Wochenende hindurch denn zwei
Tiefs nehmen uns in die Mangel wir haben
jetzt Zacharias im Südosten das sagt
sorgt für Dauerregen von den Alpen bis
an die Adria und dann kommt morgen noch
das Tief herange rauscht dass wir neuen
Regen aus Nordwesten sorgt und hat
dieses kleine hoch hier im Südwesten
kaum eine Chance es sorgt immerhin dafür
dass das Wetter sich heute Nacht soweit
beruhigt dass ich sogar Nebel bilden
kann man will stillen Orten bei 10 bis
14 Grad der Dauerregen an den Alpen
bringt bis morgen Abend aber bis zu 50
in nordsternlagen 100 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter und das kann zu Erdrutschen
und Hochwasser führen und auch morgen
startet der Tag im Südosten stark
bewölkt der Dauerregen lässt erst
nachmittags nach sonst ist der Tag aber
nicht unfreundlich mit einem Wechsel aus
Sonne und Wolken erst nachmittags werden
die Regenwolken in Sachsen dann dichter
und auch von Westen kommen dann die
neuen shower und kurzen Gewitter mit
auflebendem Wind die Chancen auf Sonne
sind am größten von in einem Streifen
von der Ostsee bis zum Schwarzwald je
nach Sonne erreichen auch bis zu 23 Grad
zum Beispiel am Oberrhein im Dauerregen
gibt es aber nur 17 Grad oder weniger
und es wird noch kälter am Sonntag und
am Montag teils 10 Grad zu kalt für
diese Jahreszeit dazu gibt es viele
Wolken viele Regen viel Wind erst ab
Dienstag kommt dann der Umschwung das
war es von uns an dieser Stelle wünsche
ich Ihnen ein schönes Wochenende